the church is brought to you by onyx go
to honor.com right now and press in
church and get 10 off any of your
supplements i can't help you with the
weights and the [ __ ] gorilla bells
and [ __ ]
but shroom tech you know uh hemp force
all that type of stuff i got you
go to honey.com right now are you hiring
do you know where to post a job to find
the best candidate
let me help you out go to zip recruiter
find out today why zip recoup has been
used by businesses of all sizes to find
the most qualified job candidates with
the most immediate results that's
ziprecruiter.com
church and right now my listeners could
post jobs on zip recruiter for free
that's right free just go to
ziprecruiter.com church
again ziprecruiter.com
church
the church is brought to you by onyx go
to honor.com right now and press in
church and get 10 off any of your
supplements i can't help you with the
weights and the [ __ ] gorilla bells
and [ __ ]
but shroom tech
you know hemp force all that type of
stuff i got you go to honey.com right
now are you hiring do you know where to
post a job to find the best candidate
let me help you out go to zip recruiter
find out today why zip recruit has been
used by businesses of all sizes to find
the most qualified job candidates with
the most immediate results that
ziprecruiter.com
church
and right now my listeners could post
jobs on ziprecruiter for free that's
right free just go to
ziprecruiter.com church
again
ziprecruiter.com slash church kick that
[ __ ] mule lee
[Applause]
the church [ __ ] awesome
monday the 25th of september
as good as it [ __ ] gets right here
get ready to [ __ ] shoot yourself
right here many nights on acid i was
ready to shoot myself right
here yeah
[Music]
are you kidding me or what
turn off [ __ ] rihanna it's over this
is it [ __ ]
[Applause]
this might be my favorite sabbath song
of all time either this or uh a national
acrobat
um off of uh
i love that love that song tremendous
he's got a couple of those jams that you
listened to when you were young you're
like i don't know he's onto something
yeah what's that king of the world what
is it oh lord of this world oh lord of
this waldorf master reality yeah that's
amazing let me tell you something jim
doing the first time i bought master
reality i put on three songs i took it
off and i swore i'd never listened to it
you didn't like it or it was freaked out
it freaked me out it was just too deep
for uncle joey my mama just died oh i
bought it the same night the exorcist
was on tv
and i put the album on as i was watching
the exercise doing homework and i'm like
what the [ __ ] hang the pope on a rope
yeah do you think he's a fool get this
[ __ ] off my and i liked volume four and
sabbath play sabbath and technical
ecstasy and the whole thing that arm i
didn't get back into years later that
was a really pro-god album though like
after forever is kind of pro-god it's
funny i argue with a religious teacher
about this in high school my gym my gym
teacher was a born-again christian
uh who would always do coke and uh he
[ __ ] the students and he eventually
overdosed and died but he was like a
real christ pusher what a great story he
was yeah yeah and we would talk about
this and and the album he was like it's
against god i'm like no it's actually
pro-god it was uh it was kind of coming
from the point of view of criticizing
people who didn't uh believe it was an
odd song for sabbath to do you really
loved them from them i did my favorite
people of all time bigger than kids she
loved them more than the kiss was longer
um you know it's funny kissing my first
idols my first heroes were kissed i i
you know can they make up when you're
seven years old you know i mean men in
[ __ ] makeup how little did i know how
long that would carry over for but uh
you know when you're a kid they're like
giants they're like [ __ ]
you know they're gods they had the heels
that make up fire like as a kid they it
was just larger than life
but sabbath is my favorite ever they
can't not be i love him love him love
him [ __ ] naomi's an animal he's got
stage two cancer and he you know did the
album and did the whole tour did two
tours
with stage two station cancer
unfucking yeah what's going on in your
world great to have you out thank you
it's good to be here i'm okay i'm
touring again so i'm like kind of like
obsessed with [ __ ] ticket counts now
it's not fun to tour because all you
think about is is
am i dying is it over am i finished am i
finished it's a [ __ ] horror show what
am i doing that's not sold out uh it's
half sold or it's three quarters sold
like what i yeah you know it's not fun
it's not about the gig
and then you do the gig and people laugh
and both shows so far that i won't jump
down to seattle and portland they were
amazing the crowds were amazing but i
still find fault in it because they
weren't sold out like they were nice
crowds but they weren't it's like you
can't win
you know i feel like i can't win i mean
by when i mean be happy like i can't
just feel good that i'm touring and
people are loving the material you know
what i mean i look at the negatives
we all do yeah i guess so i wasn't
filled up but there was still 2 000
people
who gives a [ __ ] yeah i don't think they
left they [ __ ] giggled they knocked
themselves out
i see hey listen i just look at the same
thing a couple weeks ago that [ __ ]
conor mcgregor fight the whole weekend
was great till saturday night yeah and
you know the tickets went on sale after
i took the [ __ ] game sure so you knew
what saturday night was going in when i
got the numbers for saturday i was
heartbroken was it a club it was a club
you know i did like 150 of your show i
was heartbroken but that that that was
it that's a fight it's a giant rogan
said he did 2200 seats but 500 people
didn't show up
because [ __ ] uh they announced the
mcgregor fight after the tickets were
tickets on sale so my dad worked at
nightclubs and he would be pissed when
it would rain like there's just some
things you can't you can do everything
hologram they sell out with a hollywood
[ __ ] hologram though people want to
go out on sunday i want to go to the
movies yeah you come to town it's a
tough you know i love stand up more when
i was broke i think you're right i loved
it when i was just [ __ ] around going
to bars lucky to make any money lucky to
make 30s or 50 and 80. you struggled
once you get and all you want is an open
mic or a feature actors to headline it
yeah then it becomes this different
[ __ ] situation radio and tickets and
oh do you have a publicist i need a
[ __ ] publicist now all of a sudden
because the club don't want to do the
work even though on the [ __ ] thing
they bang you for three grand for
advertising sure sure what the [ __ ] what
advertising you're doing i want to see
the [ __ ] ads yeah that's where you
need a road manager you actually look
for the receipts for the [ __ ]
receipts it's uh it's one thing after
the other to really catch him you gotta
[ __ ] bring 22 [ __ ] people and
bring somebody with a [ __ ] seat
counter because you know half these
clubs pad the [ __ ] place with an
extra 50 chairs well yeah they do matter
of fact kenny has caught them before and
kenny was coming with me he caught a
club putting in almost 50 extra seats or
when you have a good thursday like yeah
we papered the room well you know the
contract said you could only have 10
[ __ ] seats
unless we approve and they do it anyway
they're all shitty they're all shitty
man so i i get why why people get big
and then kind of act shitty uh or scummy
to them but uh you know the obsession
over take accounts and that kind of
stuff it just defeats the fun of doing
it and then at times it's not fun
because you obsess over the business
side of the other side of it and the
laughs don't even matter like you start
looking at the ticket account since like
all the laughs don't matter because who
cares how many people which is stupid
it's the wrong way to look at it but
it's hard not to fall into that
no it's a tough [ __ ] way then your
agents call you hey
the club wants to do those things those
two full ones what do you think they
were spying and get one the other one
what's the
goal star
that drives me quick because then they
do it every night yeah you got to get
the thing and they did 22 groupons and i
really yeah 22 groupons a night you did
you thieving [ __ ] no you didn't
no you [ __ ] didn't there's not even
22 people on [ __ ] groupon yeah
they have one groupon i love it i've
never been on it i go on it oh yeah for
different [ __ ] what do you buy
one time my acupuncturist was in israel
so i [ __ ] had to go to a different
chick to get cupped
so i bought five cuppings over here on
studio city from some [ __ ] chick that
smelled like incense and [ __ ] it wasn't
even worth the aggravation intense a
nice smell though no but she was too
creepy for me if it was two it was two
l.a oh okay i got an old jewish lady
from the village that [ __ ] throws a
couple needles in me once a week with no
drama there's no skepticism do you like
i did acupuncture recently it actually
helped i fell asleep on the table yeah
no no it's tremendous and the first i
know for i know one thing for a fact i
usually go to acupuncture on tuesdays
and it sucks because they tell you when
you go to acupuncture do yourself a
favor drink two gallons of water and
stay home and put your feet up don't do
dick right but tuesday night's such a
big comedy night you got to go out sure
but i'll tell you what there's times i
fall asleep on a tuesday and i sleep
hard and it's from those needles hey
they do it for you
put a couple extra needles for sleep
they wind your engine down there's a
[ __ ] thing in your ear well when i
walk in she'll play it's like a piercing
and she'll he'll [ __ ] spin she'll
make it spin
on the way home i'm like why the [ __ ] i
should have brought a pillow yeah from
the 405 or something like you ever get
them i get the needle sometimes over the
fingernail hurts um between the toes
hurts in the middle of the forehead uh
i've gotten them everywhere but between
the finger webbing hurts toe webbing
hurts oh and the ones that hit the
little bone above your [ __ ] right
right where the skin meets your finger
[ __ ] idea i don't do the feet
i don't mind the feeling
you know she could you know ask you a
little lady next time you go pull her
aside throw an extra 15 let me ask you
something
i want a heart on i could drill [ __ ]
streets with
and those chinese people they got a
[ __ ] way that they'll put 22 needles
in you and your dick will get so hard
like i asked them once i go all this
stuff with testosterone do you have a
treatment for that she goes yeah but
it's done through the feet
it's a [ __ ] nightmare it hurts like
[ __ ] really i think they get a hearted
dick it's through the feet too
she's told me already because i've been
going on for 10 years 11 years so i have
you know i [ __ ] around with them and
then the crowd say off color [ __ ] do it
so i asked them once anybody come in
here to get that car and she goes i have
a system that's so good that the guy
came back
and said turn it off really because he
was [ __ ] everything he couldn't stop
[ __ ] so what is it that it does i
guess it just gets the blood flow it's
all blood it's all tall blood yeah the
the all that it's like cabbage yet in
your feet it was so weird how my ankles
were really [ __ ] swollen that's when
you know a fat guy is about to go
when you see a fat guy look at his
ankles i don't care if he weighs 900
pounds if his ankles are skinny he's got
a chance yeah but when you see those big
ankles and it's trying to get red he's
got a couple days left yeah and my
ankles are like that and she told me she
goes well first i'm going to do is
to get that blood flow today because all
acupuncture really is is circulation
yeah circulating through all those what
do they call those things veins no
chakras or chakras yeah there's
different spots and they put the needle
in there and they got a lot of different
[ __ ] going on i mean they really do
chakra is a good pervert word this is
how al gore you know hotel al gore had
that thing with a massage therapist and
then i believed her because she said
that al was saying um
hey my uh
my chakras need work that's that's like
a midsection word where you want a girl
to put her hand by your dick that's why
i believed her because she said that uh
al is asking for his chakras
to be massaged and if you say that
you're a [ __ ] creature you're a
[ __ ] creep you're a creep whatever
happened with uh
i forget his name now the guy who has
the plane he was in greece he had like
eight muhammad atta no no the
whatever the white guy's name is he had
like six or seven male
uh
massages
travolta whatever happened i never heard
like a ending to that story they pay him
off i'm guessing the church of
scientology sends a guy with a black
suit
and they give you a check for 30 grand
they say move on with your life then
they break them to your house and steal
it from you
they're [ __ ] creepy [ __ ] people
scientologists they'll give you the
check but then they'll do something to
you to [ __ ] with your life you know i'm
saying like tarot has done that i don't
know you know travolta is fun he's a
weird kid i think everybody feels that
he is but nobody
can prove it there's a picture of him
kissing a guy like in a plane and
it just goes away i don't know how and
then some people [ __ ] drop an n-bomb
on twitter and their careers are ruined
you know what i mean it's amazing what
can stick and what can be you know have
that whole de la hoya panties thing go
away but because listen panties wonder
woman suit in the closet what's the code
guy that got the [ __ ] spider-man suit
in the closet the coke guy carried no no
no no the other guy that he was he's a
great actor you know he uh
uh less than zero when he went deep and
then he came back robert downey jr
robert downey jr he got caught with a
[ __ ] batman suit in his closet and
the whole [ __ ] thing with a bag of
blow
listen that that [ __ ] is very passe
you know what
joe rogan's gay jim norton's gay joe
diaz his gail there's some fun
you got nobody you got a picture of jim
norton swap and spit with arty lang who
gives a [ __ ] nobody wants this i'd like
to see this i'd like to see this
anthony would love to see that
but
it's so funny how it's passe
you know
john travolta is gay tell us something
we [ __ ] don't know yeah who cares
tell us something we [ __ ] don't know
anymore it doesn't mean anything uh
somebody told me that that kevin hart's
in trouble again yeah that's a [ __ ] no
one cares he's a millionaire he's gonna
he's gonna [ __ ] 80 000 women at three
million pop and they don't even dent
this bank account yeah okay who who who
else got look at this other guy he's got
a [ __ ] cult he's still selling
records pissing on you oh ra r kelly
yeah kelly
yeah some [ __ ] sticks but then kathleen
[ __ ] griffin puts a picture of a
[ __ ] president with her heads right
and she gets canceled even from [ __ ]
did you no
that [ __ ] even bananas canceled that
when bananas cancels you in jersey yeah
you're in trouble you got a [ __ ]
problem you could always
so who knows what the [ __ ] you're going
to do that's going to end it right it's
the stuff you don't see coming you know
the major ones
it's the one thing you say on twitter
it's the one rebuttal you say to someone
you call the roman a [ __ ] or something
like that or you comment on how ugly
your kid is and you find out at the
special needs kid and you didn't know
it's only that one thing that snowballs
that somehow sticks but then some guys
are just teflon i guess it all depends
on the crisis management team you have
working for you if you have enough
people and enough lawyers you can shut
anything up are you guys careful about
what you say on email now i'm careful
about everything i say that can get me
sued publicly and uh yeah and an email a
careful sure emails have been coming out
a lot recently and it seemed like i
think people used to think it was
private but it's coming out well what
what would you write on email like i
would never threaten somebody an email
people do it i would never go to a chick
and say you suck my dick on an email
there's no [ __ ] track paper that's
common [ __ ] sense well this is things
you'll say like uh you know you could
talk [ __ ] about somebody that you know
to somebody else you might bash somebody
to somebody else and then all of a
sudden it comes that's right it's sony
they caught these people talking all
this [ __ ] about the people that you know
performers yeah
[ __ ] them they deserve to get busted
you're gonna just pick up the phone and
go jim norton
i don't really like the [ __ ] yeah god
knows that call's been made before in
showbiz yeah why the [ __ ] are you
emailing people back and forth
to let people know what you think it's
on paper yeah would you i'm married i
don't want nobody texting me saying do
you want to lick my balls my phone is an
abomination it's an abomination my phone
nothing but [ __ ] filth
i finally cut the text off did you you
can't text me no more nobody can
yeah done i didn't know that was a
service yeah that's the same why because
i'm sick of them it gets out of control
it just did they just go crazy you
better call yeah just call me because if
i call you i said to the [ __ ] out yeah
but the taxes go you don't even know
who's texting you half the time i don't
even know who's texting me after that
i'm addicted to it i'm addicted to that
rush of that little red like it's hard
not to look at my phone i resolve crisis
through my phone i everything is done
through the phone what kind of crisis do
you remember just any type of like i'm
having this relationship thing now where
i'm just really frazzled man and my
ex-girlfriend's helping me actually uh
we're talking a lot and i'm like just
going through it do you think that she
might have meant you know
i'm just dysfunctional i'm not saying
that because you think comedians are
supposed to be dysfunctional i'm [ __ ]
49 and i stink
at being involved i stink at it
i'm terrible at it it always ends badly
you know i don't know what i want
how long you married
i'm with a 17 [ __ ] wow that's that's
that's good yeah but it's something that
i don't know
i don't feel i feel like at times i
don't give a what i should like uh yeah
but
we're setting our ways chip you know
you're setting your ways when you come
to relationships
this [ __ ] i won't even [ __ ] tolerate
in my world like i don't i don't even
know what the [ __ ] you're talking about
and that's why i lost my first wife yeah
this is the second time i've been
married what will you tolerate
just
i don't we have one [ __ ] life
somebody says they love you you love me
that means don't break my [ __ ] balls
all right that means just don't break my
[ __ ] balls i i after five years
you get to understand a person's
patterns
and i get you get to understand my
patterns even if we're [ __ ] roommates
right i get to know your patterns
so how [ __ ] stupid are you
you know what i'm saying that you can't
figure out what is going on here and i
can't figure out what's going on with
you my problem is i i figure out the
pattern but then i i don't like
something in it so i try to change their
pattern i get mad when they try to
change mine but i love to figure out
that pattern that's a good way to put it
but then a lot of times i see things i
don't like in it and i harp on those
things and i try to change the i'm a
[ __ ] psychopath like i really am
crazy man me too but this is the thing
you have to look at people some like
when i was young
if a girl sucked two dicks i wouldn't
date him really yeah i was really not
only would i date her i'd kiss her when
she was done i was one of those facts oh
i'm a [ __ ] i was one of those please
creep out if if i went to a bar and i
was talking to a girl and you pulled me
aside and said i [ __ ] her in the ass
two months ago i i don't need to talk to
this really
you wanted them pure i wanted to have my
i don't want them to [ __ ] uh
because some world on the line is gonna
bother me it will you know and i had
that problem in my 20s and early 30s and
then one day you're like who gives a
[ __ ] will they [ __ ] look at the [ __ ]
animals you [ __ ] i finger banged an
indian with a yeast infection [ __ ] uh
in idaho who am i the judge where a
woman blows if she blows a hindu or a
[ __ ] dirty homeless dude what do i
give a [ __ ] what i'm saying so you you
just
and other things you also start lowering
your standards sure just like women do
when you're 22 everybody wants pharah
fawcett when you're 40 and you're single
you'll take a chubby chick yeah a
cesarean scar and a [ __ ] missing
tooth yeah yeah she's got insurance you
got a nice car but she'll work harder
too yeah she'll work she'll work harder
it's that that too but
i didn't want to die alone jim knowing
when i was young i wanted to be charles
bronson
i want to live by myself be rugged i
don't know what you're talking about
backhand women
you know and push them and [ __ ] and
leave them money after you [ __ ] them
like charles bronson who wants to die
alone you know i've been thinking about
that too i'm 49 and i i i don't feel
like a midlife crisis where i want to
buy a sports car and and i'll meet the
younger child i've always dated a
younger chick but now i just feel like
yeah man you've been alone a long time
you're set in your ways
um and i kind of met somebody recently
who i think i fell in love with
and i just think it's falling apart now
and it's been really [ __ ] depressing
me like really depressing me that i
couldn't make this work
and i i might still be able to make it
work i don't know
but if this one doesn't work i mean i i
don't know what options i have because
this one seemed on paper to be perfect
and it's not but i'm not i'm [ __ ] up
like it's my [ __ ] i think
she's not perfect but my [ __ ] just kind
of i like to test people and then when
they don't pass i can leave them
it's crazy what's a test
you know
put a scenario where i'm gonna somehow
be less than
like i remember one girl
i was
making her tell me that her boyfriend
had an ex-boyfriend had a bigger dick
and i was somehow convincing her to say
that she preferred that and she was like
no i like your day but i just wouldn't
stop and then when she said it i felt
devastated but the goal all along was to
feel devastated
so it's almost like none of this is
about the woman it's all about me
feeling [ __ ] up i want to feel bad
like i like to my ex-girlfriend just
pointed out to me she goes you like to
be wronged
and i'm like i do like to be wronged i
like to be [ __ ] hurt and wounded it
feels natural and comfortable like that
feeling
between your your throat and your
appendix scar we got oh it's like that
that ache that you had when you were a
kid and you wanted to date a girl who
didn't like you like i've told this
before but in high school my fantasies
about girls
i used to fantasize about being in the
high school
auditorium or in the uh lunch area
and being savagely beaten
like with bats
and being bloodied and fighting and then
somehow
uh she liked me after like i always had
this weird association of like horrible
things happening and then love comes
first the horrible thing
and then the love comes in the like
resolving the horrible thing like i
don't know why i felt like i had to have
that
awful feeling in the stomach before i
could enjoy being loving so when i
didn't get that naturally i set it up i
tried to set it up and make it happen
it's crazy
very interesting it's it's it's
something that's
when you get on stage how do you feel
depends on the night depends on the
ticket counts depends on where i am some
nights i feel great and creative it'll
go away
uh what do you mean all that feeling yes
last night does it all go away last
night
i was in portland
and ticket accounts weren't what i
wanted wanted but the crowd was amazing
and i before i went on i was in such a
pit
sitting upstairs in the green room i'm
like i really want to [ __ ] throw a
belt around my neck i'm like really
don't wanna and i always do shows
but it was absolute despair and then
when i was on
it went away and i still felt it and i
was still thinking about it
but the crowd was so good and you know
how it is when you're feeling creative
and you you feel great and it was just i
felt so disastrously bad that nothing
mattered on stage so it was good you
know when you're free you're usually
much funnier and i felt very free and
comfortable
um and then right after i was right back
to where i was
so but that uh you're but it all did go
away
on stage it was great
you're a brilliant guy thank you i don't
finish this goal
talk to somebody see what you could do
you know like guys like you and me will
never go talk to nobody colin i called
colin quinn today uh
you know i was in a bad way today and i
called him and uh he's like yeah go to a
therapist and i'm like yeah probably
what an age now it's too much what's
that
we're at an age now you're 49 i'm 54.
it's it's really no difference
this business has worn us out
relationships have worn us out life
and also me i've worn me out my own
nonsense he said no no we're all the
same it's just you know what i turned on
[ __ ] cnn a month ago on a sunday i'm
at home with them and
it's a show about comics and depression
and i'm sitting there going these
[ __ ] don't have a [ __ ] clue
that's not to do with depression
it's what
we brew with inside
as comics were always brewing something
in our [ __ ] heads i'm an only child
you know reefer feeds the [ __ ] parade
in my head you know i'm writing a book
right now i'm trying to get the
the first four chapters for the proposal
and after chapter three i'm like what
the [ __ ] there's no women in these books
when i was younger i wanted to get my
dick sucked snort coke and smoke pot
relationship
wasn't going to happen right you know
how i think
let me tell you how perverted i was
i'd look at a woman and go
what the [ __ ] am i going to do for her
i'm a thief i got no job i got no high
school diploma i got no family
what am i gonna do for this [ __ ] girl
i would talk myself out of him
yeah i wanted to [ __ ]
do a couple lunches
maybe a hand job maybe a movie and once
you started talking about family and
kids i'd disappear yeah because there
was nothing i could do for you as a man
nothing plus did you want to do that
though like meaning
absolutely
no i wanted a family i had my family my
sister's in cuba jim my mother's in a
hole my father's in a hole you know yeah
i wanted to build my own thing but what
the [ __ ] was i going to do for this
pretty girl who didn't even smoke dope
what was i going to do right what was i
going to do
everything yeah what was gonna do get a
car and do a robbery
eventually it would just [ __ ] her up
right you know i feel bad for the chicks
that i did blow with and suck my balls
like today they must be sitting there
just going like this with their face go
what was i thinking that night you ever
think about that [ __ ] like she was a
dirty [ __ ] uh-huh she's at home 20 years
later going jesus christ i put butter on
his nuts
i licked it what what the [ __ ] you know
did she let your girl do that to you who
me yeah oh i did that to them you know i
put anything on your [ __ ] whipped cream
chocolate syrup i'm a savage i put syrup
up your ass oh i don't like the sweet
stuff oh yeah i put a little syrup on an
[ __ ]
it's like a dairy queen sundae without
the cherry he just licked that
[ __ ] he liked that oh a little
syrup on them i like it raw and plain i
like it wrong playing a little sweaty
yeah i like them to go to yoga maybe do
some jumping jumps like push-ups like
bike get a city bike ride home yeah
that's a little bike ride home
where they [ __ ] torture that [ __ ]
yeah i love what
look at people i look like you said a
little sweaty and you're talking about
yoga class a bike ride
that's delicious
and that little bat opens up and that
little whiff comes out of sweat and
[ __ ] the judge yeah but you're
talking about the [ __ ] you're not
talking about that yeah that's the same
it's got some wang to it that's it i
like that you put a little sniff to it
you know but you like what do you what
do you sniff before you bite into this
something particular your mom makes it
you go
with your nose that's what you do to the
ass you get a little whiff always and
once you whiff it you commit it even if
it smells like deck you got to lick it
then those nose when
do you go do you go with like the tip of
the tongue or is it like like a ice
cream cone you go the whole way oh if
it's dirty it's the tip of the tongue
and you take your chances
and if it's [ __ ] delicious then you
lick it like it's uh you know
if it's dirty what you do is the old
trick is you get your mouth really wet
and you drip spit into it and then just
lick your own spit that's a trick to
take a lot of the stink out like that's
one thing you do with an [ __ ] is
dirty and i've gotten my share of dirty
ones oh my god i've gotten my share and
sometimes it impresses you when the
chick shows up with a dirty ass or
you're like you're a [ __ ] savage you
know that's how bad you are i don't mind
if it stinks a little like i like body
scent on the right person which is why
it's so hard with this girl i'm knocking
i don't want to date because her body
said it makes me crazy it's hard to find
that it's hard to find that how long
have you been with her nah we've only
been dating exclusively for a little
over a month we've been talking since
december we've gone on vacation together
i just i don't know man i think i think
it's done i don't know i hope it isn't i
hope i hope not too you're a fun guy but
i'm not always forgiving like i i can't
let things go
do you ever like
are you do you ever have an argument but
in your head you're like this isn't
really as big of a deal to me as i'm
making it yes because i like the high of
the argument sometimes that happens i'll
be like oh this isn't like i'll notice
i'm like that's not i'm just i'm just
saying these words and i don't i don't
apologize but it's just
i don't know i've noticed and it's i i
noticed it because i didn't notice it
before when i was younger and i would
get i would like lose friendships or
something
and now i see it but i don't stop it
yeah it's hard too you're it sounds like
you're watching a movie of yourself yeah
arguing like one thing with this girl i
haven't done i actually got this advice
from bill burr of all people was like
dude no name calling and i always called
names [ __ ]
bit always i thought that's how you
argued and uh this one is the first one
i did even though we're having a thing
now and we had a long talk today that
was not pleasant but it wasn't nasty i
didn't curse at her i didn't go yeah but
you're [ __ ] up i kept telling like
look i'm not mad at you it's just this
is what it is you're not [ __ ] like i
didn't i didn't a lot of the stuff i've
done before i didn't do this time
um which again like that whole thing
where you're saying horrendous [ __ ] to a
person like how am i saying this to this
person
this is terrible stuff i'm saying but
you're like watching a movie at yourself
it doesn't feel real and then when
you're done you're like
that was terrible i still
wake up in the middle of the night the
arguments i had with my ex-wife
thinking of him
yeah
how out of bounds i was and how out of
bounds she was you know and uh
how you get into your car and you just
[ __ ] boil
you're hot because she said things that
obviously hurt you yeah but even you
saying those things to her
destroy you you know they take a piece
out of you you know
i spoke to mike's wife about two years
ago and i stopped during the
conversation i told her so listen
whatever happened outside the courthouse
that day or here or there i'm really
sorry about because till today i still
remember those conversations and
we're young we're stupid
that's what part of it is you know yeah
you learn and
that's it's something about myself that
i like
with this woman
is i've been honest with her
like i'm a liar when it comes to
relationships i lie i cheat i'm [ __ ]
i'm despicable um
and then i feel victimized if you lie to
me or cheat on me
but with this girl i was straight and uh
she's pretty straight with me too she's
young
she's not perfect
um
you know and i have to realize that
people make mistakes too like you got to
give people room to [ __ ] up not a
devastating [ __ ] up but she [ __ ] up
and she talked to someone she wasn't
supposed to talk to
um and she she might have been willing
to hang out with him i don't know
um but they didn't she never you know
she met the person she was talking to
him
so i'm like how do i want to ruin things
over this
i don't know
you know what i mean like do i want to
take that [ __ ] i'm justified wrecking
the relief i don't know if i want to
ruin it or not
that's a real crossroads the last couple
days has been bad pretty bad how many
[ __ ] relationships
did i end that everybody got hurt
because
i couldn't get over something small yeah
it's exactly not getting over harping on
it i i couldn't get over something small
like when i lived with the stripper for
four years those were the worst
arguments i had every night
i acted like a [ __ ] child like a
[ __ ] child did she ever do something
she wasn't supposed to do with a client
though all the time she was a dirty
animal
she was a dirty animal what and you know
you date people you hang out with
somebody somebody says to you
hi jim how you doing you start dating
them awesome you go how do you make a
living you're like well from 12th to 8 i
said i'd deliver coke
yeah you know what i'm saying you would
never hang out with somebody who did
that sure but because a [ __ ] is good
and you kind of love her you tolerate it
for a [ __ ] while yeah and then pretty
much pretty soon you know she's you call
her at lunchtime and oh i went over to
her clients and he invited me and we did
a few black what are you talking about
you know right there's always those
after the stripper
i dated a couple girls it wasn't gonna
[ __ ] work and i met my wife and i
liked her and i said you know what this
one would play completely different yeah
i'm not doing the same things i did with
the other three
because you have here's the other thing
too
you dated people when you were just a
civilian
dating people is a comic is a completely
different [ __ ] animal unless they
know their life
unless they know their life at the
beginning the first 96 months it's a
great time oh my god jim is so cute he's
so funny oh my god how do you live with
huh we went to dinner then
one day when he disappears for two weeks
and you're knocked up with the [ __ ]
kid you know they don't like you that
much no more when you're calling up
going me and joey went to sparks
steakhouse nice and she's in idaho in a
[ __ ] three-bedroom house with
everything but she's like i'm stuck here
with a kid it don't last the laughs
don't [ __ ] last yeah they want to
they get jealous they get angry at
resentful of the life you have in fact
you're out and she's not out
why i keep it light i go out three days
a shot i come right home jim norton you
do right yeah i come right up
i've i really worked hard on this
relationship so she's not alone for long
yeah i really really real in the
beginning i was an animal the first five
years was a relationship i was a [ __ ]
animal
i was on the road constantly sure
holidays i come back
christmas day
her birthday never celebrated at the
first time
as always december 29th
you're doing new year's weekend is that
where our birthday is yeah oh you're
doing the [ __ ] new year's gig gee
yeah of course and number two when
you're broke i got to come up with a
christmas present a [ __ ] birthday
present i gotta disappear for you
i gotta get that new year's day check
and then come back and go oh my god i
had your present yeah i was away i was
away the whole [ __ ] deal
uh i worked with her really weird the
first five years and then when i was
shooting the longest yard was when i
realized i'm going for this no more
[ __ ] around with her this is a waste
of her time
and a waste of my time and i went for it
and i worked on it
you know i really worked on it and
that's why i didn't want to go out of
[ __ ] one time loser that killed me
the hardest part
is like is is like you said when you're
wronged
it's hard to forgive another person like
because again i like to feel wounded i
like to feel shitty so when they do
something that wrongs me
that's what i wanted because now i feel
i can keep using it to make myself feel
bad
you know what i mean so i like so i harp
on it and i keep it because not because
i can't forgive somebody but because
it's such a valuable weapon i can use on
myself i can feel so
shitty whenever i want by bringing that
up and i can sabotage our good time
whenever i want just for that little
[ __ ] thing a little you could be
dinner across from her a month later
think about that and steam yourself up
and i'll just and then start asking
creepy questions so let me ask you this
that time you went online you said you
didn't know who it was i thought about
it and i went on just we got [ __ ]
creepy yeah i used to do that [ __ ] i had
to cut that off so you so you i knew i
know you were texting with them what do
you mean you weren't gonna meet up with
like yeah like they i don't know why but
if they grill me like that i'm like you
know i'm angry and i'm sorry
and then sometimes you're right that's
the worst there are times when you're
right like yeah she was being a shady
[ __ ] and i caught her
that's the worst that was the worst
curse i've ever had is that i've been
right a few times
and then when you're right a few times
you never let it go you never you
because you never can like
because it felt the same
or
if she lied to you about something and
you know what now you know what her
lying face looks like like oh my god you
sincere kind you looked exactly like you
did when you said i love you two days
ago the same genuine look on your face
and meanwhile i know you were [ __ ]
instant messaging with this other guy
while i was talking to you
a baby i love you so much
with someone else
so so basically what i'm saying is you
have the same ability to lie i do
because i'm a liar so it's like it's
hard when i know that she has the same
ability to lie that i have you know i
like to be the only one who can do that
and by the way whenever a woman tells
you i'm a terrible liar shut up no
you're not
no you're not
no woman who says i'm a terrible liar is
a terrible liar they're great liars
relationships we can't live with them
yeah and we can't [ __ ] live with it i
don't know how to i don't know how to
not i don't know how to not
hang on to stuff i don't know how to do
it do you ever like what about like
something that she didn't even wrong you
would feel like like that one like not a
seinfeld joke but like inside feel like
ah i don't like the way
she sleeps or i don't like the way she
she drives or like something weird that
has no impact on your life you know i i
haven't had that with this girl for me
it'll be normally something physically
like i'll look at her from the side one
day and i'll be like oh no
she has a [ __ ] rocky dennis smile
or she has a [ __ ] wall that i hate or
whatever it is and i won't be able to
unsee it
so it's usually a physical thing for me
not not like
something she does can be something she
does but you gotta be with someone a
little while that usually takes a little
while to sink in i hate when my wife
sneezes why because she sneezes like a
[ __ ] animal out of nowhere and it
scares the [ __ ] out of me and the cats
and every time she sneezes i want to
[ __ ] stab her she has a rash of
allergies
and they just hit her out of nowhere so
it could be one in the afternoon it
could be two in the morning
she could be
taking a shower and all of a sudden
she'll just go ah chew like a [ __ ]
like a giant yeah
like a [ __ ] giant and i get oh my god
it's like who taught you how to [ __ ]
sneeze you want to sneeze like a lady
yeah
dog i do [ __ ] that tears my wife up i
tell you what i hate
i hate when people put jelly on their
toast for breakfast and pisses me to fly
that's the newest one it just bothers
the [ __ ] out of me right jelly be an
american and use buddy you want to use
jelly dude on youtube about both
i was a cream cheese and jelly guy i'm a
[ __ ] east coast guy always was one
day i just didn't see the value in
eating [ __ ] jelly for breakfast i got
i gained 80 [ __ ] two pounds oh yeah
all right physically yeah but it is
tasty it's delightful what do you eat
for breakfast egg whites with jelly no
plain oh my and mustard egg whites and
mustard i'm such a piece of [ __ ] this
was in the airport and i think they used
like pam or something in the pan because
the egg whites smelled like dog [ __ ] so
i couldn't eat them and i had to wait
for till i got to la and i had a
delightful breakfast of eggs and uh no
no uh bread
just some chicken and dip in it i like
to dip [ __ ] i'm a dipper
like i like to have chicken to put my
egg yolks did you flying today i did i
flew in this morning what airline um
american did they give you breakfast no
air alaska i flew from newark to seattle
to start the tour and um
air alaska is a weird uh airline it was
okay but not great they bought virgin so
did they really yeah virgin america yeah
has been bought by air alaska wow i
wanna left i think last year it's alaska
era alaska oh i'm sorry
i thought i didn't know there were two
little uh stand lines what's that
there's not okay let me check it tara
alaska i believe or is it alaska air you
know what you might be right joy might
be right
i'm saying with authority that's because
i'm a phony i said it with authorities
it's terrorist i don't know i don't know
i just wanted alaska airlines there you
go you're right joe now they're owned by
american guys
because when you take them you get
american points i know that yeah when
you take them it's american [ __ ]
airlines you got the water nobody no
it's american airlines and you take them
so it really doesn't matter i didn't
know they bought [ __ ] virgin i didn't
they bought it oh no i'm sorry they
brought in march
so now american owns virgin uh let's see
yeah they're killing off the virgin
brand
why and are they killing off virgin
america yeah apparently lucy why it was
a great airline that's what i thought
there must be a reason that flight that
you where'd you go newark or laguardia i
knew you took newark uh to alaskan air
to um
seattle and then i took um
we drove to portland and then from
portland took american
and i go to dallas in austin this
weekend i don't know what airlines i'm
taking then home
my favorite cross-country flight is
mint
yeah mint is good here's a problem with
mint though those seats are blown up so
a couple of times they've deflated
and then it's like that hard it's like
hitting metal under the seat i made a
video of that once they have to come
over and blow it up with something
they have to squeeze something so it
blows back up perfect the that mint seed
how good is that middle one when you get
the one alone that's the only one i get
i can't always get that i always get it
i don't know how to this next flight in
november i'm doing them i got them both
it's nice right two row two like a
doctor you're deep in the cockpit yeah
if the plane crashes you go first yeah
you like one of those pablo escobar
flights you just go first that's a great
plane the mint ones are nice i really
like i really enjoy it they're not
better first class but that one's it's
comfortable it's comfortable i like
laying back i like the movies i put my
sleep apnea machine out wait wait you
you uh you could use your machine
my nose is so bad i see your nose is bad
too i can't sleep no no no i did the
surgery you talked me into it everything
that you i did you i asked you oh good
we were both hooked on the [ __ ] nest
yeah
and i finally couldn't take it no more i
mean i was living in anxiety if i went
on a plane and i put my seatbelt on and
i went in my pocket and i didn't have
afrin
that was the flight from [ __ ] hell
yeah the whole flight i'm blowing i'm
just i just uh went swimming okay
yesterday with the baby so i get that
[ __ ] in my nose but i went and had the
surgery done and i'm off the [ __ ]
spray oh i shoot a steroid every morning
i got a [ __ ] i got a shower with plugs
in my ears doesn't that dry you out the
store i hate those steroids they make
the inside of my nose i feel like
there's plastic coating in it i don't
[ __ ] know haters i'm lucky just to
breathe out of my [ __ ] nose that blow
and the [ __ ] getting beat up
destroyed my face oh yeah yeah
so so the mask works for you
the mask
i couldn't live without the mask how do
you fall asleep with it i'm so
claustrophobic and plus it's right it's
forcing air in to like
i'm gasping maybe because i'm a shallow
breather but like i doze off and like
so how do you sleep now what do you have
to do i have a mouth guard rogan taught
me to a mouthguard but i'm on my side
all the time and i'm just constantly
waking up i'm always tired did you go to
his doctor for the mouth guard no but
one who had a similar mouth guard i have
a good mouth guard it pushes you off
hard but the tongue falls back but i
have two kinds of apnea
how long does how long do you sleep
before you wake up i don't know but i'm
always i'll remember always being in a
state of like perpetual
half awakeness when i was sleeping
um i haven't slept much in the last
couple days because of trouble with this
girl i can't
sleep when i have conflict with a woman
like that i can't sometimes just go to
sleep i admire those guys i can't i'm
[ __ ]
like i just i obsess about it i was
panicking last night i panicked
yesterday afternoon i couldn't nap
so i had to resolve it somehow
it's great when you fall asleep and
you're breaking up with somebody and
you're [ __ ] hurting
and you fall asleep and you wake up the
next morning and you forget for 10
minutes
right you always forget for like the
first 10 minutes a day like [ __ ] it
comes back oh with me it's like 10
seconds i'll wake up happy but then it's
over
it goes away well like not always but if
i'm if i'm upset about something yeah do
you have you married now no i've been
with the same girl for like four years
so it's it's we and we're living
together so it's close but
and we have a really good relationship
but there's i see myself ever since
we've moved in together doing some of
those things you've been talking about
are you gonna marry her
i think so
it's it it's
i see these people rushing into marriage
and it freaks me out
i'm i love rebremen no rush to get
married yeah how old are you 29. oh yeah
young okay
i should have been married a long time
ago i got married when i was
20 something 25 maybe before i got
locked up i had no idea what i was doing
how about the second time
now we're solid how old were you when
you married her
i think maybe i was uh 37 because you're
54. no i was when i married
terry i was probably clean from coke for
a year so
45. oh okay
and now i'm from yeah you've been
married nine years yeah together
it took me nine years to [ __ ] marry
the animal yeah you know it took me nine
years but i wanted to be sure also
that after nine years she was walking
around like wounded
because you're still not married our
parents are alive
and i said let me marry you i kept it
light we got married at the [ __ ]
chapel on wilshire we had the party at
the hollywood bowl
and uh
we made our own cake we ordered [ __ ]
pastrami from canters
some cuban pork chops and we got rented
some fried chicken that was it man yeah
we got married on a wednesday night very
unconventional
no suit no gifts just show up and eat
something to show your [ __ ] money
shut up and [ __ ] yeah so there's no
driving you know what's good i make
people [ __ ] you know i
i got married the night before
thanksgiving so on the way home you can
stop over there
but that's hell over there getting
people to highway but there was no
concert that night and nothing tonight
was terrible you went up that yeah
monday night you're gonna get killed
really yeah monday night stay away from
highland if you gotta get on the one on
one of the 170 always go up kawanga uh
yeah that was that google maps yeah
google maps puts you with other [ __ ]
traffic that's what they live for that's
what's [ __ ] worth waze is better
waze is better waze teaches you how to
drive like a portal google maps [ __ ]
sucks waves tells you to cut that white
car off yeah
cut that white car if they don't give a
[ __ ]
you know hollywood is bad especially
coming in that direction at that time it
wasn't moving
it wasn't it was double no
you there's that bank coming off like a
franklin or whatever and it was like 15
minutes no no no no so what you do is
you go to uh
hotel 101 what's that joint that's got
the breakfast in there yeah uh
it's on uh it's
right now it's not the gower exit it's
one of those that one's always empty jim
norton it's in los angeles you think
it's got to have
that route is always in lowe's police
that's why if you see that traffic boom
and you stay on that [ __ ] road and
then you'll see it you're going to
underpass the 101 cafe 101 cafe once you
see the 101 cafe bed of your left and
it's like one of those [ __ ] polish
u-turns because there's actually a left
but then no there's actually a left and
then there's a tight left where you have
to shoot and go around and that's the
101. okay bang it up there's never
nobody there you know lois feliz i i
lived there when i was shooting lucky
louie
um that was the best place that i got an
apartment on western i think it was cold
and western it was really fun i liked it
a little far from where i wanted to be
but i liked the neighborhood it was like
a weird hippie vibe to it like a weird
like alternative counter culture
and mentality at least
i liked it a lot man they got a
restaurant they called chicken fred was
one of you see that is that it isn't it
birds right birds right thanks to ucb i
don't know birds yeah they do they have
a tremendous chicken soup
really yeah you can't go in there the
[ __ ] place is always packed you gotta
go in and take it to going at lunchtime
oh okay it's one of those places where
it's always [ __ ] packed
and there's always a line so i would
have to do make my reels over there so i
would go there at 10
and make my appointments at 10 45 i'd be
up there talking [ __ ] till 10 after 11
i'd shoot right down and get [ __ ]
chicken soup that's what you wanted was
a chicken soup oh it's delicious it's
spicy
and they take the chicken breast and
break it with their fingers like my mom
used to do ah she used to do that with
fish soup every lint
you take fish and you break it up soap a
picao and every once in a while you got
a little thorn in your [ __ ] yeah and
your throat you know what i'm saying
yeah i had one in my throat not long ago
it was from a piece of fish and it's an
awful feeling like i don't know if i'm
gonna choke to death but it's an awful i
had to take something and scrape the
back of my throat and it came out it was
a bit that long like a real thin white
little fish bone it's a disgusting
feeling of something in your throat my
brother wow what's your next big uh
anticipated ufc fight
um you know i want to see dilla shaw
against cody a lot that's a great card
that's an amazing card man i want to see
you on against rose is a great fight
i've been waiting for that fight
um
uh
you know demetrius against
ray board you know i'm sure it'll be a
good fight but i'm not i don't look for
that one as much as are you going to the
garden
um i don't know i'm i'm in la the night
before working i'm doing the roxy so i
don't know i think isn't is mass vidal
fighting
that's a fight i would love to see
um
mike perry i like watching a lot he's a
fun welterweight to watch you know he's
kind of he's a kind of an animal at
least
yeah i want to see him fight ponzinibio
i've been screaming for that for [ __ ]
six months
and now what's the main event of uh
of new york oh uh gsp against bisping
yeah that'd be great
i'm looking forward to that one that's
gonna be it's a great card it's a great
card i'm in omaha nebraska as usual
isn't it weird like you want to go to
one of them and you're like
but i'm in new york that wednesday that
following wednesday the 8th
so you're just gonna miss it i'm just
gonna [ __ ] miss it that's my luck i
might fly back that morning i can get
back from la
maybe and see the fights but i'll be
tired and i might you know
how was the last garden event you be
amazing it was it was amazing i mean
um we had good seats you know and uh i
wanted eddie alvarez to win and uh you
know i was his wife was screaming i
remember as well you can hear his wife
on the tape eddie
she's like you know i guess that's what
she does at the fight she just screams
yeah she's a philly girl
and um that was a hard one to watch i
like eddie so much and watching him lose
to connor like as soon as he looked like
you deer in headlights that night it was
like he wasn't even in there like
somebody put something in his milk yeah
i swear to god it was like he got hit
and he got up and he got right back to
where he got hit let me come right back
to you i think he was he was just
overwhelmed he was shell shocked the
iron it was the garden he was the main
event and they were rooting against him
in his almost his hometown you know 90
minutes from home uh thompson [ __ ]
woodley was great
uh on that car that was that was a great
disappointing ending to a fight but it
really it was that was a fun night the
whole thing was just
who else fought you are you and jay
chick fought on that one oh yeah josie
aldo frankie edgar that was a great
[ __ ] card
that was great card you know i used to
go to all of them now you get busy can't
you're working you're like what the [ __ ]
am i gonna do do i go to i want to go
see jones it's right here
and that's the weekend i'm in [ __ ]
the borgata it's right here in my
backyard yeah jones uh call me and i'm
in the [ __ ] borgata it's always
something always something and you can't
plan for it and i'm almost like hey look
you know is [ __ ] daniel cormier
taking off to come watch my shows
you know you do when you can see them
when i'm off i go but i i you know even
like work for the ufcs i'm doing the
podcast i mean i still would uh
go only if i'm off
i'll watch them i usually watch the
fights the night i get home or the next
day i watch them on fight pass
unfucking believable i gotta tell you
man it was a real pleasure having you on
tonight how long did i know you got a
boogie right okay you got a boogie by
nine
yeah no it was a real pleasure having
you on i wanted to uh it's great that
the conversation went where it went yeah
you put some heavy [ __ ] on the table i
apologize i'm i'm being a little boring
i'm i'm i'm tired and i haven't slept
well in the last couple of days i'm
looking i admire your [ __ ] resilience
i can't believe you're here you flew
you're here
and then you're going to do another
[ __ ] podcast at 10 minutes
pre-taping for tomorrow morning we get a
three-hour show die once i fly it's game
over i take pills when i fly i gotta
take drowning means i get sick
yeah so i take motion sick pills my
daughter has to do that also she gets
sick i gotta [ __ ] put bands on her
yeah do they work though is that just
psychological who the [ __ ] knows what i
just do is starve on the way down
and starve on the way back if you've got
nothing in your stomach you can't throw
up puke
yeah we leave at six she doesn't eat
real quick
she doesn't get up and want to eat she's
one of those kids that she'll milk it
for 45 minutes by that time we're
already in the [ __ ] danger zone we're
back already oh yeah yeah yeah so i did
it that way and now we're timing it
uh we were eating and then going down to
[ __ ] san diego she puked by the time
we got to the comments casino we were
like in shock sure she's gonna [ __ ]
puke how old is she
now she's four and a half well i had
that same [ __ ] me too i got cars sick
with families and gonna say your family
would say you want to go swimming with
us up and [ __ ] niagara yeah
next thing you know they got to pull
over the station wagon i barked in the
back [ __ ] seat
oh
happy humiliating so i couldn't really
do much at a young age because i was
always embarrassed i was gonna get
[ __ ] cars sick
how are you
how helpless is it when you're in the
back seat and you feel it coming and you
have to go could you pull over because
you roll the window down
the air on the face feels a little
better you try to just stare straight
ahead
um and you feel it coming you're like
you gotta you gotta pull over you're
gonna vomit you don't even you say it
one time and then like they start
questioning you
that's the [ __ ] up thing maybe all
right
why what do i have to pull over for
because i feel sick are you going to
puke no i'm telling you to pull over
because i want to see the [ __ ] trees
pull the [ __ ] over and by the time they
pull over respect do you remember the
old station wagons yeah opening from the
back the window went down and the old
station wagons had a bucket seat in
front a bucket seat in the back and then
in the back they had a little hatchling
if you picked up the carpet you could
make another two seat for kids and strap
them down back that was the best you
know that was the best seat in the whole
[ __ ] world but that seat got me
puking like a [ __ ] because i was
going against the wind
so you gotta go facing backwards yeah
get it forget it that's the [ __ ]
there was a time when southwest had i
was just i don't like southwest for that
same reason because you face backwards
on some flights i won't do it they had
no they got rid of those oh really yeah
the ones in the middle there was a time
where there was you had to sit with
people across you
three and three
and one day i got on one of those
flights after an eight ball night you
know what i'm saying in chicago i'm
coming down off that battery asset and
before i get on the plane i open my
wallet
and i see these [ __ ] things
that you put under your tongue that
rogue and was big on those uh thc
strikes he had boxes of he bought half
the company
so he gave me a batch and in those days
you couldn't if you put them in your
wallet they were like a condom you put a
wall in your condom in your wallet no
after a while
one of those little bucket seats across
mystery women
that are coming to l.a to see like
disneyland like they really [ __ ]
think they're coming to see the seventh
creation of the world
very sweet women
awesome that thc kicks in
it was like three strips i had never got
that that cocaine was still working on
me i started sweating profusely i had to
puke but before i puke i went into the
sweats
where every every hole in your body
shoots out a piece of sweat
so actually i'm i'm 390 at the time
about
375. it's about the year i did the
longest yard not really and i had to
take off my shirt
and i was in the middle of two other
guys and then just like look at him with
no shirt no shirt on tit com sweat is
coming down my chest
and you could see the beads of sweat on
my nipples before they dropped out my
jeans my stomach was sweating god knows
what odors were coming off did you puke
at the end yeah i puked facing backwards
uh i ran no here's how i puked with my
shirt off i walked through the cabin
open the bathroom and just heave like a
[ __ ] savage is there anything worse
than when you're in a limo and you're
going backwards and you ever sit in that
front seat in the limo and you have to
sit there kind of turned over and facing
the driver you can't even talk to the
other people in the back of the car
because you're gonna vomit you have to
look forward it really is torture i take
every precaution now like i look at
things and go god damn it
i'll take a chance trains when you get
on a train you know uh i always have to
ask the conductor which way
is it leaving because if i get on if
it's going to the right and i face that
way i'm going backwards i'm going to get
sick so actually like a [ __ ]
eight-year-old have to ask the conductor
which way is the train going and he's
like that way so i have to face forward
unfucking believable we did a podcast
about feelings and phobias that's right
and vomiting and vomiting vomiting and
being queasy and little sabbath to start
my brother thank you very much anything
that you want to promote talk to me just
kneeling room only is my tour jim
norton.com
uh what cities are you going to um
everywhere in new york
um i got here in l.a indianapolis
oh dallas and houston all the money's
going to the hurricane victims so if
you're down there
um everywhere chicago philadelphia long
island new jersey
and um the chip chipperson the live
podcast is now up people who like stupid
chip
and uh jim and sam every morning i love
you to hold my heart man thank you for
having me on it thank you for taking the
time brother great time joey good luck
thank you
thanks dude
the church is brought to you by onyx go
to honor.com right now and press in
church and get 10 off any of your
supplements i can't help you with the
weights and the [ __ ] gorilla bells
and [ __ ]
but shroom tech
you know hemp force all that type of
stuff i got you
go to honey.com right now are you hiring
do you know where to post a job to find
the best candidate
let me help you out go to zip recruiter
find out today why zip recoup has been
used by businesses of all sizes to find
the most qualified job candidates with
the most immediate results that
ziprecruiter
dot com slash church
and right now my listeners could post
jobs on zip recruiter for free that's
right free just go to ziprecruiter.com
church
again
ziprecruiter.com slash church kick that
[ __ ] mule lee
[Applause]
the church [ __ ] awesome
monday the 25th of september
as good as it [ __ ] gets right here
get ready to [ __ ] shoot yourself
right here many nights on acid i was
ready to shoot myself right here
[Applause]
[Music]
are you kidding me or what
turn off [ __ ] rihanna it's over this
is it [ __ ]
[Applause]
this might be my favorite sabbath song
of all time either this or uh a national
acrobat
um off of uh
i love that love that song tremendous
he's got a couple of those jams that you
listened to when you were young you're
like i don't know he's on to something
yeah what's that king of the world what
is it oh lord of this world oh lord of
this waldorf master reality yeah that's
amazing let me tell you something the
first time i bought master reality i put
on three songs i took it off and i swore
i'd never listened to it you didn't like
it or it was freaked out it freaked me
out it was just too deep for uncle joey
my mom had just died i bought it the
same night the exorcist was on tv
and i put the album on as i was watching
the exorcist doing homework and i'm like
what the [ __ ] hang the pope on a rope
yeah do you think he's a fool get this
[ __ ] off my and i liked volume four and
sabbath play sabbath and technical
ecstasy and the whole thing that arm i
didn't get back into years later that
was a really pro-god album though like
after forever is is kind of pro-god it's
funny i argue with a religious teacher
about this in high school my gym my gym
teacher was a born-again christian
who would always do coke and uh he
[ __ ] the students and he eventually
overdosed and died but he was like a
real christ pusher what a great story he
was yeah yeah and we would talk about
this and and the album he was like it's
against god i'm like no it's actually
pro god it was uh it was kind of coming
from the point of view of criticizing
people who didn't uh believe it was an
odd song for sabbath to do you really
loved them from them they're my favorite
people of all time bigger than kids you
love them more